hello and welcome back to omix logic
transcriptomics in this session we will
speak about exploratory and comparative
analysis important steps that need to be
understood and used properly by anyone
who would like to perform meaningful
analysis of transcriptomic data and be
able to interpret the results in
biological terms
in this session we'll review the
limitations of data visualization
and see how we can explore large data
sets including methods to identify
global patterns and interpret them we
will look at how to define specific
contrasts based on our exploratory
analysis and then how to turn to a
comparison using hypothesis testing to
find specific genes that answer a
criteria that we sent
so at the end of today's session you
will understand these concepts in detail
and have the ability to practice and
apply them using a variety of tools such
as the tbi info platform excel r and
python
let's start by reviewing again some of
the ways data can be visualized and what
limitations we face when a large number
of observations have to be studied
together as a whole
this will also serve as an introduction
to data mining
an important topic that combines
multiple methods that allow us to
understand a structure of a data set
and find specific methods to interrogate
the structure and find differences that
we are interested in
remember that we are working with a
table of expression where columns are
samples
rows are genes and the numbers in each
cell can be raw or normalized counts of
reads mapped to a specific region on the
reference genome
in the previous session we discussed how
such data can be explored visually
looking at individual gene expression
patterns across samples like a bar plot
or by summarizing gene expression for a
single sample
but all the genes using global
properties like the mean
median maximum minimum or distribution
and how we can compare these global
attributes between samples we also
discussed the significance of normal
distribution which is not typical for
gene expression data but very important
for comparing samples so as a result we
looked at filtering normalization and
scaling which are all typically applied
first to fit the data to the assumptions
of some statistical analysis methods
that we rely on
these methods are important for
statistical analysis but also for visual
comparison for example after log scaling
filtering low values and normalization
we can visually clearly validate
important assumptions about the data so
here you can see a distribution in a
histogram for two samples and then those
two samples plotted against each other
using a scatter plot now we can compare
these samples and find genes that are
highly correlated and those that are not
we see that the bulk of our data is
correlated and so our assumption about
these samples belonging to the same
group are correct
these visuals are especially important
when we do not have control over
experimental design and use data that
was generated by someone else either
from a single lab or multiple labs so a
quick way to compare multiple samples
and understand global patterns across
the full data set is to visualize the
data using box plots where each box
represents a sample
and if we color them by group we can now
see global comparison between these
groups but these rough data summaries
can be very misleading as we can see
when we compare the information in box
plots and histograms
box plots are useful to spot the
strongest signal present in each sample
but they also reduce a lot of data to a
minimum information
but complex visualization like the
violin plots make it much more difficult
to compare global patterns in our data
between samples and across many samples
or groups of samples so how can we
capture all of this variability in
detail and at the same time explore
relationships between samples or groups
of samples
to answer this question let's explore
what information is contained in each
one of our genes
and find
what kinds of associations we can start
looking for using multiple features or
multiple genes in a data set so here we
can see one gene a feature of a data set
or a gene expression pattern this visual
helps us spot
some patterns of similarity
for example some samples are highly
expressed
other samples have a low expression
we can compare them by taking the mean
and calculating full change
dividing
one mean by the other
and we get a result of about 3 or 3.28
in some cases this is not enough
information and we would like to find
additional sources of information to
differentiate between these samples
further
so now we can add a second gene
instead of using a bar plot we'll use a
scatter plot
gene 1 is the x-axis and gene 2 is the
y-axis the previous samples that we
looked at
are similar according to gene 1 or on
the x-axis but they're far away
according to gene 2 or the y-axis
instead we can start seeing more complex
patterns for example sample 3 6 and 7
are close together on both
x and y axis
but other samples also have some similar
and interesting patterns so when we take
all of our samples but two genes the
amount of information increases
and the patterns become more complex
in this multi-dimensional plot the
patterns are becoming more complex but
we can use a visual representation that
is turned in a specific way to find
interesting similarities between our
samples and even find a way to separate
them according to a single line
we now understand the need for
dimensionality reduction when we have
all of our genes
we cannot visualize it but we understand
the significance of this information as
a whole
so how can we combine all of these
different methods and try to get a
meaningful visual for a space that we
definitely cannot understand
to understand what principle component
analysis does let's take a look at this
projection
so let's imagine we have
this cloud of dots
and the cloud of dots can have a low
variance if we just look at our axis x
and y
or it can have a high variance to
maximize the variance we need to find a
projection in the space that is not
either one of the axes or the features
that we have
and turn
this sample set in such a way that the
axes maximize variance
so if we're using this approach of
principal components we're looking for a
plane in the multi-dimensional space
that we cannot see that explains
variance in our data in the best
possible way
now we can compare samples or dots on
the scatter plot or sample groups using
the principal components that accurately
represent all of the features in our
data
let's see how other biologists use this
technique
by looking at several publications
the first publication is titled
transcriptomic analysis of calcium
remodeling and colorectal cancer in this
section about principle component
analysis the author is right we found
that pc1 clearly explains the difference
between phenotypes since the projections
of the values for each sample over pc1
show how the samples belong to a healthy
phenotype and are well separated from
the samples belonging to the tumor
phenotype
given that pc1 clearly reproduces the
two different groups related with the
phenotype it is interesting to evaluate
the influence of each original variable
gene which is proportional to a
coefficient associated with the linear
combination for each gene so we see that
the authors apply principal component
analysis to the data they evaluate how
accurately the pca represents the
original data and now they can evaluate
the phenotype information that they have
about differences between normal and
cancer samples the principal components
allow them to start looking into genes
that are correlated with the principal
components or simply use the separation
between groups of data to start
comparing individual genes between those
groups of samples the second article is
titled transcriptomic analysis
identifies gene networks regulated by
estrogen receptor a
and b
that control distinct effects of
different botanical estrogens
where the authors compared estrogens
produced by plants in terms of the
effects they might have on gene
expression patterns and breast cancer
cell lines this is the portion
describing their use of pca these
comparisons among the four estrogens
were examined further by principal
component analysis pc8 which enables one
to visually assess global similarities
and differences between sample groups
expression patterns for all compounds
were different from those in vehicle
control treated cells
so the authors here used pca to explore
the data and assess similarities and
differences between four groups of
samples to understand what kinds of
differences emerged from all of the gene
expression patterns
later they used the insights from pca to
quantify effects of different compounds
on gene expression networks
so let's now see how to perform such
analysis
first we will take the gene expression
table and filter out genes with zero
values across all samples and even genes
that have a very low level of expression
next we will head on to the t bioinfo
platform and select the utilities
section once inside upload the gene
expression table in tab delimited txt
file the pipeline we can build will
include quantile normalization where we
will transform data to log normal scale
and select a threshold of 5 as well as
pca where we can also filter the data
using various thresholds
as a result of principal component
analysis we will get a table of values
for each principal component associated
with each object or a sample in our data
set columns will also contain a
percentage of variance that each
component explains
we can visualize our data by assigning
coordinates for each sample based on the
principal components that best explain
the variance of our data now we are
visualizing the samples on a scatter
plot using principal component analysis
results notice that we can see a
distinction between samples of the
triple negative and estrogen receptor
positive samples by their position on
the x-axis we also
see that there's an outlier sample in
the triple negative group based on the
y-coordinate
another way to run pca and annotate the
results is to use r to do that first we
need to add sample labels in a row
called group then we can again use the
area of the tbi info platform called
data mining and find the unsupervised
analysis section the section implements
pca in r with ggplot outputs
in the pca parameters you can select
options for data scaling and centering
the output is a pdf file that shows
samples colored by group name you will
also get an output that contains the
actual r script and later on in this
video i will show you where you can
practice some of the scripting related
to performing the full pca analysis in r
one way to practice these methods is to
explore projects on the learn portal
each project contains a data set that
comes from a publication that you can
read to understand what the authors were
trying to do in this case the project is
called modeling precision medicine the
objective of this project is to find
subtypes of cancer and link them to
effective treatment in the portion that
we discuss
we use the gene expression data from 50
cell lines to find subtypes of breast
cancer and genes that can be used to
identify these samples and the
differences between subtypes another
project example is an analysis of the
cancer genome project gene expression
data called tcga liver cancer risk
one of the examples we use here is a
comparison between samples with liver
and breast cancer to see how global gene
expression patterns separate samples as
a result pca clearly shows that the
major separation between samples happens
along the x-axis which is associated
with tissue type or the difference
between liver and breast
the y-axis which doesn't have as much
variability shows the difference between
cancer and normal samples
so our conclusion is that tissue type
has a much greater
influence on gene expression patterns
overall
than the difference between tumor and
normal samples so what can we say about
pca for such exploratory analysis it can
be useful to explore patterns and data
understand major trends find features
that contribute to such variability
understand noisiness of data and find
outliers that need further investigation
we can liken pca to a photographer
trying to find the best angle for a
picture that will capture as much detail
as possible while showing us the most
information about the group as a whole
we would typically use this method to
visualize and explore data when using
this multivariate analysis method it is
important to play around with the data
using normalization and filtering while
paying attention to outliers for the
best possible interpretation to further
explore these methods and practice how
to use them just load all of the courses
on the learn portal
lesson 7 in the transcriptomics course
will introduce you to pca and provide
additional details that we did not cover
in this session it also offers several
quiz questions that can help you
evaluate your own understanding of this
method for example
which of the following is based on this
pca plot
which of the following would be useful
comparisons in differential gene
expression studies what might be one of
the interpretation of pca results of
gene expression tables
moreover lessons in this course will
offer coding exercises for pca in r
using ggplot2 here you can practice
using several different datasets to
explore global patterns
similar code can be also implemented in
python with an additional resource a
notebook that you can keep all of the
code and solve a challenge that we offer
to summarize
pca is a part of
exploratory data analysis
in a classical setting we have control
over the experiment design so we can use
it to identify trends and data that fit
the design of the experiment
when we work with data
that we didn't generate and we want to
understand pattern we also can find new
insights about data sets without any
previous understanding of the samples in
the classical example we first developed
a model to set thresholds that we're
looking for and then we perform data
analysis to see whether the data can
explain the model when we talk about
exploratory data analysis we first
perform data analysis to design a model
that model can lead us to select
thresholds for comparative analysis